These are the cerebral hemispheres. They may look similar. But our hemispheres
differ in size, shape and function. Thus even though the cerebrum is divided
into two equal hemispheres. We now know that the left hemisphere processes
information in a focused and analytical manner. And the right hemisphere
intergrates information in a more broad manner. We see that insights and
solutions to ideas are more likely to occur in the right hemisphere. However,
the hemispheres do not operate independently. Let's look inside so I can show
you why this is. Here we have the Corpus Collosum. This is a thick band of
fibers that connects the two hemispheres and this band allows for extensive
communication between the two hemispheres. This is really important for things
such as logical thinking, even creativity. From research we know that the
biggest functional difference between the two cerebral hemispheres is language.
Both speech and language abilities involve the left hemisphere. However, they
involve different parts. The first neural scientist to discover this was a man
named Paul Broca. He found that a man who had a stroke could understand
language but could not speak grammatically correct sentences. This man had what
we call Aphasia, which is a deficit in the ability to speak or comprehend
language. Due to his research, the part of the brain that's responsible for our
ability to actually produce speech. Is named the Broca's Area. The part of the
brain that's responsible for the ability to speak in meaningful sentences. And
to comprehend the meaning of speech, is named the Wernicke's Area. It was
discovered by Karl Wernicke. If there's damage to this area, the type of
aphasia that results from this is fluent, grammatical streams of speech.
However, they have no meaning. So, they're grammatically correct. They just
don't have any meaning to them.